Casting is underway right now
to find out who will play Madonna
in the movie of her life.
A Hollywood reporter says competition is stiff.
Everyone in Hollywood wants this part.
And all they have to do is impress the director
whose name is Madonna.
(all laughing)
Madonna, she's also writing it and producing it
and working with casting director, Carmen Cuba,
to find the star,
and auditions have been going on for months.
And this is who we're hearing
is still in the running right now.
Tell me now, Rossi.
Okay. Are you ready?
I'm waiting.
Okay who watches "Ozark" or "Inventing Anna"?
(audience cheering)
Okay.
Then you know Julia Garner.
She's in the running.
Florence Pugh, Oscar nominee from "Little Women"
is in the running, and Alexa Demie from "Euphoria"
in the running as well.
(audience applauding)
Okay, I have a favorite, I think,
who'd be so good in this role.
Tell us, Rosie.
Okay.
So I'm obsessed with "Inventing Anna,"
I just watched it, and Julia Garner, I think,
is one of the best actresses around right now.
I mean, look at her on the left.
She even looks like Madonna.
She does look like a young Madonna.
Right?
Give her that little gapped tooth
and I'm sold.
Sold.
I am such a Florence Pugh fan,
though
Of course.
I mean, she could do action, she can do period.
There's nothing she can't do.
And Miss Demie from "Euphoria"
also has that hot moxie that Madonna had.
She just kinda catches you in her web
whenever she's on camera.
She's got such spine.
These are just great women.
So I'm very excited.
Well, you know why?
'Cause with Madonna's story,
there's a lot of material, girl.
(Drew and audience laughing)
Stupid, stupid. (laughs)
Dish it up, Rossi, dish it up.
Well, next up it was Fashion Week in Milan and Paris
and the main event was the red carpet.
But you know who owned it?
Rihanna. As usual.
The woman who literally changes the world
with each decision that she seems to make.
She showed us again how to be a pregnant woman
out in the world and put that baby bump front and center.
Oh wow.
She's literally showing people
kind of how to celebrate the pregnant body.
I've not seen someone dress, time and time again,
in their pregnancy the way that she's doing it.
She is breaking the mold yet again.
Like she always does always.
(audience applauding)
Always.
Yeah. Like the hottest trend at fashion week is the womb.
You know?
Yes, exactly!
And Rihanna brought it.
Totally.
Yes, thank you, Rossi.
You put better words into my mouth.
Well, up next, more movie news.
How about this?
A cult classic might be getting a sequel
34 years after it first came out.
Nylon reports "Beetlejuice" part two is in the work.
Say it three times.
Beetlejuice, beetlejuice, beetlejuice!
Yes! The script in the cast are not confirmed yet.
But here's what we know,
Brad Pitt's production company, Plan B,
has officially taken on the project.
And they're partnering with Warner Brothers right now.
They're working on it together.
So could we see Winona Ryder back
as Lydia Deetz all grown up?
Or Michael Keaton back?
And, oh please, that is one of the most iconic performances
in the history of time.
Ever.
Michael Keaton as Beetlejuice.
Ever!
Ever.
You know, I auditioned for "Beetlejuice"?
For, just imagining, Winona Ryder's part?
Yeah.
Okay.
And then I saw her at a party and she was like,
"Yeah, I just booked a movie."
And I was like, "Really?
And what is it?"
And she was like, "Beetlejuice."
And I was like, "Oh, I'm so happy for you.
I'm gonna go make a straight-to-video movie
with Kris Kristofferson, hit rehab,
and then I'll see you two years later
at the Academy Awards.
You'll be wearing couture,
I'll be wearing Betsey Johnson off the rack.
You'll be with Christian Slater,
I'll be with Corey Feldman."
Oh my God.
That's the best story ever, Drew.
But she actually taught me
my most valuable lesson in life.
What is that?
Always be happy for people.
Oh yeah. Yeah.
And that there is enough room
to go around for everybody.
And everybody's timing is different.
And I just fell in love with her
because Winona Ryder, for me,
is a symbol of how I conduct myself in life.
And she's like my poster girl
for knowing that you need to celebrate everybody's wins.
Come on.
I know.
We just got that.
That was a gift.
All right, and as we go into commercial break,
I wanna give a shoutout to another great young woman
who I'm totally obsessed with, Joey King.
She's a friend of the show, she's a friend of mine,
and she just got engaged to her boyfriend, Steven.
And I just wanna say a big congrats
from all of us here at the show.
(bright music)